Y respecto a lo de ETA,
¿qué quiere que le diga?
Sabía que era el comodín que iba a utilizar
era muy previsible.
Yo solamente le diré que usted, aquí en esta cámara,
probablemente
con algún tipo de aforamiento que yo desconozco,
solamente que usted se conoce las leyes españoles
mucho mejor que yo.
Nos ha llamado, eh, parte de ETA, ¿eh?
Nos ha imputado.
Me ha imputado a mí directamente, eh,
la comisión de delitos.
Que si usted tuviera la mínima prueba,
la mínima de que eso es cierto,
yo probablemente no estaría aquí, sentado,
sino en un presidio y pasando las canutas,
que es como a usted le gusta que lo pasen los presos.
Pero sabe que no puede probar nada de lo que ha dicho
contra mí ni contra mi partido Euskal Herria Bildu,
porque usted debiera saber mejor que nadie
que Euskal Herria Bildu
pasó el filtro de la ley de partidos
que usted, no yo. Usted,
diseñó y pergueñó
para hacer imposible la voz
de la izquierda independentista vasca.
Más allá de eso,
no voy a perder mucho tiempo,
porque prefiero quedarme con fotos del presente.
Dado que usted es pasado, señor Aznar,
aunque se empeñe en no serlo,
molestando a Rajoy o a quien haga falta
durante un tiempo,
usted es pasado
y yo me quiero quedar con el presente,
con un presente o un pasado, si acaso muy reciente,
el del acto de Rentería el otro día,
donde una víctima de ETA
Olvidada por ustedes,
que no pudo
ni ha podido reunirse ni con zoido ni con casado,
tuvo a bien venir a Rentería
a un acto que organizaba el ayuntamiento
gobernado por Euskal Herria Bildu,
a estar con el alcalde
en un acto de homenaje y reconocimiento
a la víctima, que era su padre,
un policía Nacional, creo recordar, asesinado por ETA.
Por tanto,
esa es el futuro que construimos en nuestro pueblo.
Y luego no se basa ni en el odio ni en el rencor
de las palabras
de su de su pasado